thank you napb for inviting me to
present today my name is nicholas
morales and i'm a fourth year phd
student
majoring in plant breeding and genetics
i'm also minoring in statistics with a
focus on data science as well as
minoring in environmental information
science
my co-advisors are dr kelly robbins and
dr lucas mueller
today i will present my research
detecting genetic and local
environmental effects
using high-throughput aerial imagery
my research aims are essentially
two-fold
first i want to understand the genotype
by environment for g-by-e effects
present in the collected aerial image
high throughput phenotypes
specifically i'm looking at g by e rage
originating from local field effects
such as from soil heterogeneity
from soil elevation soil curvature
or composition
as we collect more data across years and
field locations we can then look at g by
e across these environments
the high throughput phenotypes i'm
currently looking at are simple
vegetation indices such as ndvi
however from the collected aerial images
we can potentially extract more
informative and predictive features
other than vegetation indices
ndvi was a good starting point given
research indicating it is a heritable
phenotype indicative of plant health
secondly
i am to monitor the stability of those
high throughput phenotypes for genotypes
across environments and across the
growing season
i intend to use reaction norm models to
look at genotypic deviations
across environments in the growing
season
to probe these questions i'm flying an
unoccupied aerial vehicle or uav mounted
with a micasense 5-channel
multi-spectral camera
this camera captures images in the blue
green red
far red and near infrared spectra as you
can see here on the right
it has been a great learning experience
working the logistics of flying
throughout the growing season
from getting an faa license to
transporting and maintaining the uav
the uav flies a pre-programmed path over
the field at an elevation of 25 to 35
meters
i'm flying over
hybrid maze field experiments
in the genomes to fields program
over the over the past uh three years
now
i'm also flying over alfalfa field
experiments but i won't show this here
today
i try to fly twice per week over the
entire course of the growing season
then tither for phenotypes are extracted
for each plot for each time point
image breed is a web database software
i've developed that allows drawing plot
polygon templates
such as the one
[Music]
shown on the right
in blue and red
the plot images are then saved along
with the
extracted high throughput phenotypes
i'm very proud of the image breed tools
because they are an end-to-end platform
for processing aerial imagery for plant
breeding
images coming off the camera can be
directly uploaded to image breed and
high throughput phenotypes extracted for
each plot
imagery builds on breed base which is a
database
we developed in lupus mueller's group
and is currently still in development
this first public publication roughly
describes the aerial image tools
and processing
and the second publication describes in
detail how the high throughput
how the high density genotyping data
is stored in the system
in short image read
connects the aerial images and their
high throughput phenotypes
to the field experiment
and to the high density genotype data
for the hybrids
as part of the genomes to fields program
we have high density
genomic data
giving close to a million
marker genotypes for the mace hybrids
we've tested
and this is loaded into image breed
allowing genomic relationship
matrices to be calculated
to illustrate here we can see six time
points flown over a hybrid maze
experiment
in 2019
this experiment was 612 hybrids planted
over 800
plots
again in blue and red you can see the
plot polygons that were assigned in
imagery
vegetation indices were extracted
namely ndvi
for each plot and for each time point
the collected high throughput phenotypes
can then
[Music]
allow us to see different high
see the performance of different hybrids
over the growing season
this chart shows mean ndvi values for 15
maze hybrids
across 12 time points
we can see trends across emergence
flowering and ultimately senescence
we can see ndvi show stable trends for
the hybrids
giving us assurances in our aerial
imaging methods
my research is then
separating genetic effects from
environmental effects present in those
high throughput phenotypes using linear
mixed models
the random additive genetic effects are
modeled using genomic relationships
among the hybrids while the random
environmental effects are found using
spatial corrections
and random regressions
to model the spatial correction i'm
looking at two-dimensional splines as
well as separable autoregressive
processes ar1 by ar1
these linear
these spatial effects draw information
based on the row and column positions
of the plots in the field
the random regression is distinct from
the spatial corrections in that it draws
information from the repeated nature of
the phenotype
over the growing season
the random regression has come
computational advantages over the
spatial correction
models and allows computing
a continuous covariance function across
the entire growing season the random
regression also allows more flexibility
in defining
[Music]
the covariance structure between plots
the results from all of these linear
mixed models are of the same form and
here i am showing
representative figures
they give the additive genetic effects
for each hybrid across time as shown on
the left where each line is a hybrid
across time
and they give the local environmental
effects for each plot
across time as shown on the right
each one of these heat maps is the
environmental effect present
across the field at a given time point
and i'm showing six time points
here we can consistently identify a
poorly
performing region near the middle of the
field
for instance
given that these
linear mixed models
are essentially unsupervised
and and that we don't know the true
genetic or environmental effects present
in the higher throughput phenotypes
i'm using two approaches to compare the
models
the first approach is to use simulation
and involve simulating
an environmental effect
across the time points and then seeing
how well the linear mixed models can
recover that effect
here on the left we see a
linearly simulated effect that is
constant through time
over the six time points on the right we
can see how well various tested linear
mixed models can recover that effect
with this showing
that the
the prediction accuracy of various
models and scenarios
we can see in this case that the
separable autoregressive process and the
two-dimensional spline
process can recover this effect well
here we see a second simulation where
the simulated effect follows a more
complex gradient
and is constant through time
on the right we see that the random
regression does well at recovering this
effect
there are many ways to simulate
and i'm looking at six different
processes so i'm not showing four to
four other processes here
my results indicate that
specific linear mix models are better
than others are recovering specific
types of effects
in other words not all
linear mixed models are created equally
and so
air limitary may allow us to classify
the field
based on the effects present in that
field
thereby we can know the best type of
linear mixed model to use
to account for the local environmental
effects
and to make better
genotypic selections
the second approach for comparing
these linear mixed models is to compare
with soil data we collected
so we conducted an em-38 soil survey in
2019 and in
2021
and um here i'm showing the 2019 data
uh so you can see on the left um soil
electrical conductance or ec
and then on the right soil elevation or
altitude
and i
and these values were accreting
interpolated over the field from the
soil survey
i then calculated numerical derivatives
of the ec and altitude
to look at curvature in the field so d e
c is the first
derivative of v c well d alt is the
first derivative of
altitude these are numerical two two
dimensional derivatives
and um these results indicate
that um soil elevation curvature
explains the the linear mixed model
environmental effects
well but there's more research to be
done
and i would like to thank everyone in
the robbins and mueller labs as well as
my funding sources
and if you have any questions please
feel free to contact me thank you